hey it's Justine and today I'm going to
be showing you something that I am so
incredibly excited about this is the
brand new oceanic plus dive housing for
your iPhone
[Music]
where you're with me
so this case will not only let you take
your iPhone up to 60 meters underwater
but it will also allow you to turn your
iPhone into a dive computer you may
remember hearing about Oceanic during
the Apple watch Ultra keynote where they
announced the Apple watch will now be
able to act as a dive computer and since
then I have recently started diving a
few months ago and I owe it all to this
Apple watch right here now when you're
diving you definitely do want to have at
least two dive computers just to be sure
in case something happens to one of them
now it sets this apart from some other
dive housing for your iPhone is this has
so many various features all built into
one so this has an automatic vacuum pump
that creates a super Tight Seal around
your iPhone this will help prevent any
water from entering the housing while
you're diving the integrated leak
detector alerts you if there is any
moisture detected this also will act as
a dive computer like I said but the
oceanic plus interface is where this
really shines this is an incredible
interface that gives you the ability to
take photos videos there's a smart
capture mode that will take video and
photos at the same time you can record
raw and compressed formats to take
advantage of recording in the highest
quality your iPhone is capable of it has
white Point correction for depth
adaptive adjustment so as you're diving
into deeper depths the colors start to
change this will automatically apply the
correct white balance Corrections so
your photos and videos will look more
accurate now all of these photos are
saved directly to your iPhone camera
roll so as soon as you hop out of the
water you will have access to them but
what makes this unique is inside of the
oceanic Plus app you're able to view the
gallery of all of your content that
you've shot and what's so awesome about
this is you can scroll through here and
you can see right on this depth map
where you shot the photos what the
location was and this just adds a whole
other element of metadata to these
photos like you can actually see the
water temperature when you took your
photo or video I mean that is pretty
awesome they also have some Advanced
color Corrections so when you go into
the gallery you can edit your media
directly in the app for most of these
photos I just use the automatic color
adjustment and it did such a great job
of really creating a vibrant look out of
these underwater photos and that's kind
of the hard is when you are diving into
deeper depths the color changes so
significantly this takes into account
what depth you're at so it can
automatically color those photos and
videos for you
foreign
[Music]
now the setup on this was super simple
so the first thing that you have to do
is you open it up and you make sure that
it is all completely dried out there's
no extra water inside especially if
you're on a boat while you're setting
this up be extra careful so the first
thing you'll notice is it gives you a
pre-dive checklist so you want to make
sure your Bluetooth is on the housing is
connected the housing battery level is
above 40. your phone is above 40 and
airplane mode is on and also be sure to
turn on do not disturb the reason for
this is you don't want notifications
popping up while you're trying to
interact with the interface because this
connects to Bluetooth you're able to
interact using these buttons there's
four right here and you have the trigger
button up here to start and stop videos
and take photos this is the professional
way to clean your phone
little belly action little thigh okay so
we're gonna open up the oceanic Plus app
and then we're gonna hit this button
we're gonna go scuba and we go
continuing through the setup you'll then
open the lower valve cap confirm the
vacuum cap is opened so this little slot
right here is where you're going to put
the desiccant bag and they do recommend
changing this with each dive I didn't
change it for each dive but I did change
it each day and everything seemed to
work really well next is the fun part
time to put the iPhone in do make sure
that it is all the way to the left side
so you'll get a good fit next we're
going to close the lid and when you
twist this it'll lock your iPhone into
place and now you no longer have to
touch your iPhone because the phone is
connected to the housing so you can use
the buttons to control the interface so
you hit next and this is the fun part
this is where the automatic vacuum
procedure starts and what's cool about
this is you'll see the progress and
it'll then give you a five minute
countdown to make sure that the seal is
secure this takes about five minutes but
I love that this is a safety check just
to make sure before you dive to know
that your iPhone is safely and secure
inside of the housing now once you're
underwater though this is where the
experience just feels so intuitive
you're getting that same Incredible
video quality photo quality but under
the water now when you're underwater you
have the ability to change all of these
settings on the Fly which is pretty
awesome because there were definitely
some times where I decided to switch
from 30 frames per second into 60 into
photo then to Smart capture it's also
cool because if you happen to be at a
decompression stop you can go into the
gallery and you can look at your content
that you've already filmed which is
pretty cool the other thing that I
really like is obviously being able to
have my Apple watch as a dive computer
but if I'm looking through my phone
while I'm capturing content that is kind
of like a secondary device where I can
see my depth it basically is like a Mini
Apple Watch app but right there on the
overlay of the screen so you don't have
to worry about looking at your watch so
you can not only focus on your content
but also be aware of what's happening
with your dive so this is what the dive
computer overlay looks like on the
iPhone and if you want to get some more
information you can open this up and it
looks exactly like it does on the Apple
watch and I'd love for me since I do
have my Apple watch Ultra having this as
a well actually it would be my third
device because I also have another dive
computer as well this is going to be so
cool for people who may not have an
Apple Watch Ultra and they want to have
a secondary device you can now use your
iPhone as one this is compatible with
iOS 16 and above and here are all of the
phones that it is compatible with which
is actually a surprising number of
iPhones so it's pretty exciting if you
do have an older device you can still
use this as well and of course I mean
there is a new iPhone coming out soon so
you better believe that I will be taking
this thing out as soon as I get myself a
new phone so the whole experience while
I was underwater was unbelievable and of
course coming to a place like this where
the water temperatures are warm and just
the sights are unbelievable there's so
many fish the reef is incredible my
favorite dive that we did though was
going to the Shipwreck and it was Unreal
to be just floating through a shipwreck
that I don't know how long it's been
there thankfully we had an incredible
dive guide who really helped me since I
am a newer diver really be comfortable
with all of my gear my equipment and
feeling confident enough to cruise
through the Shipwreck and even the
videos that I'm showing you guys right
here doesn't feel like I was actually
there like it feels like it was a dream
but thankfully I had my iPhone
underwater and I was able to capture
some really great shots for you now
obviously just using your iPhone on a
daily basis drains the battery so you
can imagine that after doing several
Dives the battery on your iPhone will
start getting low so if you are doing
multiple Dives in a day make sure you
charge your phone during those surface
intervals so you'll be able to have a
fully charged battery for your next dive
well thank you guys so much for watching
I'll put a link in the description where
you can check out the new oceanic plus
dive housing this was so much fun to
dive with and I cannot wait to get back
out there if you guys haven't already
please like and leave me a comment below
where you think I should dive next
because this was the place that you guys
told me that I should go next and now
that I'm here where is the next
destination be sure to subscribe and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos because it is officially iPhone
season so I'll be posting a ton of tech
videos here in the next upcoming months
so stay tuned and I'll see you guys
maybe in another dive destination peace
foreign
[Music]